This lecture is about the future of web
search.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about some possible future trends of
web search and intelligent
information retrieval systems in
general.
In order to further improve the
accuracy of search engines, it's
important to consider special cases of
information need, so one particular
trend could be to have more and more
specialized and customized search
engines and they can be called vertical
search engines.
These vertical search engines can be
expected to be more effective than the
current general search engines because
they could assume that the users are a
special group of users that might have
a common information need, and then the
search engine can be customized to serve
such users.
And because of the customization is
also possible to do personalization, so
search can be personalized.
Because we have a better understanding
of the users.
Because of the restriction of the domain,
we also have some advantages in
handling the documents because we can
have better understanding of documents.
For example, particular words may not
be ambiguous in such a domain, so we
can bypass the problem of ambiguity.
Another trend that we can expect to
see is
The search engine will be able to learn
over time.
It's like a lifetime learning or
lifelong learning.
And this is of course very attractive,
because that means the search engine
will self improve itself as more people
are using it.
Search engines will become better and
better and this is already happening
because search engines can learn from
the implicit feedback, more users use
it and the quality of the search
results for the popular queries that
are typed in by many users will likely
become better.
So this is another feature that we
would see.
The third trend might be the
integration of multi models of
information access.
So search navigation and recommendation
or filtering might be combined to form
a full fledged information management
system.
And in the beginning of this course we
talked about the push versus pull.
These are different modes of
information access, but these modes can
be combined.
And similarly, in the pull mode,
querying and browsing could also be
combined then in fact we're doing
that basically today with the current
search engines we are querying.
Sometimes browsing, clicking on links.
Sometimes we've got some information
recommended, although most of the cases
information recommended is because of
advertising.
But in the future you can imagine
seamlessly integrate the system with
multi mode for information access.
And that would be convenient for
people.
Another trend is that we might see
systems that try to go beyond, search
it supports the user tasks.
After all, the reason why people want
to search is to solve a problem or to
make a decision or perform a task.
For example, consumers might search for
opinions about products in order to
purchase a product and choose a good
product to buy.
So in this case it would be beneficial
to support the whole workflow of
purchasing a product or choosing a
product.
In this area, after the current search
engines already provided good support,
for example, you can sometimes look at
the reviews and then if you want to buy
it and you can just click on the button
to go to the shopping site
directly, get it done.
But it does not provide a good task
support for many other tasks.
For example for researchers, you might
want to find the relevant literature or
site of the literature, and then
there's no support for finishing tasks
such as writing a paper.
So in general, I think there are many
opportunities to innovate, and so in
the following a few slides I would be
talking a little bit more about some
specific ideas or thoughts that
hopefully you can help you imagine new
application possibilities.
Some of them might be already relevant
to what you are currently working on.
In general, you can think about any
intelligent system, especially intended
information system, as being specified by
these three nodes, and so if we connect
these three into a triangle, then we'll
be able to specify information system,
and I call this data user service
triangle.
So basically the three questions you
ask would be who are you serving and
what kind of data you are managing.
And what kind of service you provide?
Right there, this would help us
basically specify your system and there
are many different ways to connect
them, depending on how you connect
them, you will have a different kind of
system, so let me give you some example.
On the top,
you can see different kinds of users, on
the left side you can see different
types of data or information, and on the
bottom you can see different service
functions.
Now imagine we can connect all these in
different ways.
So for example if you can connect
everyone with web pages.
And the support search and browsing.
What do you get?
That's web search, right?
What if we connect the
UIUC employees with organization
documents or enterprise documents to
support the search and browsing.
That's enterprise search.
If you connect the scientists with
literature information to provide all
kinds of service, including search,
browsing or alert of new relevant
documents, or mining, analyzing
research trends, or provide the task
support or decision support, for
example.
You might be might be able to provide a
support for automatically generating
related work section for research
paper, and this would be closer to task
support, right?
So then we can imagine this would be a
literature assistant if we connect to
online shoppers with blog articles or
product reviews, then we can help these
people to improve shopping experience
so we can provide for example data
mining capabilities to analyze the
reviews to
Compare products, compare sentiment of
products and to provide a task support or
decision support to help them choose
what product to buy.
Or we can connect the customer service
people with emails from the customers.
And we can imagine a system that can
provide analysis of these emails to
find the major complaints of the
customers.
We can imagine the system could provide
task support by automatically generating a response
to the customer email, or maybe
intelligently attach also promotion.
Message if appropriate if the detector
that's a positive message, not a
complaint, and then you might to take
this opportunity to attach some
promotion information.
Whereas if it's a complaint that you
might be able to.
Automatically generate some generic
response first and tell the customer that
he or she can expect the detailed
response later, etc.
All these are trying to help people to
improve the productivity.
So this shows that the opportunities
are really a lot, it's just only
restricted by our imagination.
So this picture shows the trend of the
technology and also it characterizes
the intelligent information system in
three angles you can see in the center
there is a triangle that connects
keyword queries to search and bag of
words representation.
That means the current search engines
basically provides search support.
Users and mostly model users based on
keyword queries.
And it sees the data through a bag of
words representation.
So it's a very simple approximation of
the actual information in the
documents.
But that's what the current system
does.
It connects these three nodes in such a
simple way.
Or it only provides you basic
search function and doesn't really
understand the user.
And it doesn't really understand it
that much
information in the documents.
Now I showed some trends to push each
node.
Toward more advanced function, so think
about the user node here so we can go
beyond the keyword queries.
Look at the user search history and
then further model the user completely
to understand the users task,
environment, task need context or
other information.
So this is pushing for personalization
and complete the user modeling and this
is a major direction in research.
In order to build intelligent
information systems.
On the document side.
We can also see we can go beyond bag of
words representation to have entity
relation representation.
This means we'll recognize peoples names
their relations, locations etc and this is
already feasible with today's natural
language processing technique and
Google's recent initiative on the
Knowledge Graph.
If you have heard of it, it's a good
step toward this direction and once we
can get to that level of representation
in a robust manner at large scale, it can
enable the search engine to
provide much better service. In the
future,
we would like to have knowledge
representation where we can add perhaps
inference rules and then the search
engine will become more intelligent.
So this calls for large scale semantic
analysis, and perhaps this is more
feasible for vertical search engines.
It's easier to make progress in a
particular domain. Now on the service
side, we see that we need to go beyond
the search if support information
access in general, so search is only
one way to get access to information as
well.
Recommender systems and push and pull
are different ways to get access to
relevant information, but going beyond
access we also need to help people
digest information.
Once the information is found and this
step has to do with
analysis of information or data mining.
We have to find the patterns or
converted the text information into
your knowledge that can be used in
application
or actionable knowledge that can be
used for decision making. And
furthermore the knowledge would be used
to help user to improve productivity in
finishing a task.
For example, a decision making task.
So this is a trend and so basically in
this dimension we
anticipate in the futur.
Intelligent Information systems will
provide intelligent and interactive
task
support. Now I should also emphasize
interactive here because it's important
to optimize the combined
intelligence of the users and the
system so we can get some help from
users in some natural way and we don't
have to assume the system has to do
everything when the human user and the
machine
can collaborate in an intelligent way
in an efficient way, then the combined
intelligence will be high and in
general we can minimize the user's
overall effort in solving problem.
So this is the big picture of future
intelligent information systems.
And this hopefully can provide us some
insights about how to make further
innovations on top of what we can do
today.